en este vídeo vamos a hablar sobre la
fórmula de oil air y una de las cosas
con la que quiero comenzar es
preguntándonos por qué queremos conocer
esta fórmula de oilers que luce bastante
extraña que es lo importante de ella
porque es importante esta fórmula pues
es importante por que nos encanta
y subrayo esto y la razón es que cuando
derivamos
por ejemplo la derivada con respecto a x
de era la x va a ser igual a la x
y la derivada con respecto a x d
elevado a la x x esto va a ser igual aa
por el elevado a la pura x la propiedad
es que cuando calculamos la derivada de
esta función nos va a dar la misma
función o si calculamos la derivada de
la función vamos a tener la misma
función multiplicada por alguna escalar
y esto nos encanta porque cuando
resolvemos ecuaciones diferenciales
a la equis es la solución
casi siempre siempre que resolvimos un
circuito era la equis casi siempre era
la solución si ustedes recuerdan cuando
resolvimos circuitos sencillos con
ecuaciones diferenciales hacíamos algo
así vamos a decir que b dt es igual a
una constante multiplicada por e
elevada a la s deporte esta era la
solución propuesta y resulta que siempre
nos funcionaba y hay otra cosa que
también nos encanta que son las senoidal
es o los senos y los cosenos nos encanta
esto porque nos encantan a pues porque
ocurren en la naturaleza si ustedes
silván la onda de presión va a lucir
como una onda senoidal si ustedes tocan
una campana la campana se va a mover
también con una forma senoidal cualquier
tipo de música si ustedes ven las
ondas de presión que generan las notas
musicales todas son senoidal es y los
circuitos también generan ondas senoidal
es recuerden el circuito que vimos el
circuito cl que analizamos en detalle
vimos su respuesta natural y era una
onda senoidal así que los circuitos
eléctricos producen ondas senoidal es y
todas estas otras cosas también producen
ondas senoidal es todas ocurren en la
naturaleza y queremos analizar qué es lo
que ocurre cuando se encuentran
presentes onda senoidal es así que
tenemos dos cosas que nos encantan y
queremos relacionar las y la forma de
relacionar ambas es mediante la fórmula
de hoy leer y es así como conectamos
estas ideas separadas
vamos a hacerlo la fórmula de hoy leer
nos dice que es elevada a la j x es
igual al coseno de x más j por el seno
de x y en kant academy tenemos un vídeo
que demuestra que esto es cierto usan la
expansión polinomio de mclaren de coseno
y seno y demuestran que esto es
verdadero comparando cada una de las
expansiones polinomiales aquí no vamos a
repetir eso vamos a tomarlo como un
hecho y vamos a analizar esta ecuación
con un poco más de detalle esta es la
expresión que relaciona los
exponenciales que son algo que nos
encanta con los senos y los cosenos que
también nos encantan y parte del precio
de poder hacer esto es que tenemos que
usar números complejos aquí tenemos dos
números complejos y es aquí donde
ocupamos números complejos en la
ingeniería eléctrica y tenemos que hacer
coincidir la otra forma de esta fórmula
que
a la menos jx aquí pongo un signo
negativo y esto es igual al coseno de x
menos j por el seno de x estas dos
expresiones juntas son las fórmulas de
oyler y vamos a aprovechar esto tomando
los senos y cosenos que encontramos en
la naturaleza y transformarlos en
exponenciales y después estos
exponenciales los usaremos en nuestras
ecuaciones diferenciales que nos darán
soluciones a las que después les
sacaremos los senos y los cosenos es así
como vamos a usar estas ecuaciones para
resolver circuitos algo que quiero que
no tenga aquí es que vean que en ambas
ecuaciones siempre tenemos el coseno
primero y el seno después aquí tenemos
el seno en el lado imaginario y el cose
no está en el lado real
y es por eso que en el futuro vamos a
tener una preferencia de hablar con
respecto a las señales del mundo real en
términos de la función coseno y es
porque en esta fórmula de hoy leer
siempre está primero el coseno en ambos
casos y ahora lo que quiero ver es que
si tenemos nuestra señal expresada con
estos exponenciales como recuperamos los
términos de seno y cosenos como
trabajamos con estas ecuaciones para
poder encontrar el seno y el coce no
sólo tenemos que usar un poco de álgebra
si yo quiero aislar el término del
coseno lo que voy a hacer es sumar estas
dos expresiones y con esto voy a
cancelar estos términos de aquí que es
lo que quiero así que al sumar voy a
obtener
a la jota por equis
a la menos jx igualados por el coseno de
x y estos términos de senos se cancelan
y ahora puedo escribir que el coseno dx
es igual a elevado a la jota x positivo
más y elevado a la menos jx todo esto
entre 2 esta es la expresión del coseno
en términos de exponenciales complejos y
ahora veamos cómo obtener el seno para
obtener el pse no voy a restar estas
ecuaciones lo que me da que puedo
eliminar estos términos de los cosenos y
me queda el elevado al aj x menos el
elevado a la menos jx que es igual a
este coseno de x-men
x se cancela
y tengo dos veces jota por el seno de
equis de manera que ahora puedo escribir
que el seno de x es igual a el elevado a
la jota x positivo menos y elevado a la
menos jx todo esto entre dos por jota y
no olviden que tenemos esta jota aquí
abajo
a veces es fácil que se nos olvide vamos
a resaltar estas ecuaciones porque son
importantes estas son las dos
expresiones que si nosotros tenemos
exponenciales complejos y queremos
encontrar el cose no lo hacemos así y si
queremos encontrar el seno usamos esta
ecuación y pueden tratar de aprenderse
las de memoria pero a mí se me hace más
fácil que si nos acordamos de esto la
fórmula de hoy le podemos deducir las
directamente y lo otro que queremos
resaltar son estas fórmulas de aquí la
fórmula de hoy leer y el seno y ccoo
seno que podemos extraer usando
la fórmula de oilers